it's
Halloween that is really really good
timing it reminds me of the orientation
video Michael showed on my first day the
Scranton Witch Project I am so scared
when people don't label their personal
food a serial killer creepy guy who's
abducted me and is taking me out into
the Wilderness to leave me for dead no I
would never leave you for dead you would
never Escape well yes I would and I
would survive I would make sure that you
were dead believe me then I would remove
your teeth and cut off your fingertips
you could not be identified and they
would call me the overkill killer you
are you are as creepy as a real serial
killer for real okay what are you doing
I am putting this on so I have no
familiarity with my surroundings now
this way I can't retrace my steps I
don't know what streets we've been ow I
am totally alone right now with only my
thoughts I love it I'm loving
it I can literally say anything I want
no one is going to hear me wish I could
have gone with Ryan on that cool
Retreat J has plastic
boobs I have
hemorrhoids doesn't even matter Dwight
shw is now wearing a baby's Bonnet I am
not oh Carrie just walked in Dwight get
his autograph from Mich car to not just
walk in okay why what is that on your
stomach is that a Muppet baby tattoo oh
my godar you're right that is animal
from the muut you can't see my St I am
now chopping off phyllis's head with a
chainsaw did you see saw course I see
saw Mo than I see saw all the time no uh
the movie did you see the movie Saw oh
yeah great film almost as fun as going
on a seesaw Okay the reason these movies
are so popular is the element of
psychologic iCal torment I like where
you're going with this continue can we
lure him into an old Warehouse or
something I have an old barn it's kind
of smelly but that might be a plus okay
and then what we do what they did and
saw I mean we don't kill him obviously
you need to Vanquish fear one must
wrestle fear to the ground you will now
wrestle my cousin MO okay all right all
right it's over the ground this is over
okay no you're a freak I'm not doing
this anymore and this is over goodbye
don't Ryan you don't have to wrestle him
Ryan just get in the
cofin
Ryan bye
Ryan you seem
nice where are all the
animals
Toy Story Finding Nemo up I ball the
entire time I cannot watch Pixar Michael
Yes drop this one aboard why I found
twins oh my God twins I'm sorry you
understand nice to meet
you aren't they
magnificent they're men Dwight
I love finding a good set of twins
something is wrong with
you here we are irrigation room very
special room so I'll come get you before
the table making demonstration and as of
this morning we are completely wireless
here at shuit farms but as soon as I
find out where Mo's hit all the wires
we'll get that power back on all
righty
wait you're going out there yeah
coward oh my God what centy is
this
your
[Music]
turn come in did you have another
nightmare hey do
I oh
Jim I thought you were a mo just Mo up
nightmares oh yes ever since the
storm is everything satisfactory with
your
state yeah yeah great just thought I'd
heard crying or moaning or something in
here oh well I'll look into that in the
morning thank you for bringing that to
the attention of the
staff good night
[Music]
D I'm not feeling well I need to sit
down
are you
okay oh my
God oh my
God watching people get sick always
makes me sick
and frankly so is talking about it so
wow
excuse me everyone attention in the
office please Jim is about to prove his
telekinetic powers and he needs absolute
silence go
ahead okay I'll
try
oh my god when we get mad you always ask
us if we're on our periods I have to
know whether you're serious or not I
feel like I'm dying
inside I feel like Nev Campbell and
scream too she thinks she can go off to
college and be happy and then the
murderer comes back starts killing off
all of her
friends learned a lot of lessons from
that movie this is just one of
them
[Applause]
for
[Music]
oh yeah knew it knew it Kevin as soon as
I heard that rapper you really have to
say oh yeah every time you getat a candy
bar I can't help it Oscar it's just
really
good oh yeah my hands are tied all right
not bad at all I think we can beat 20
minutes though so let's try again get it
all out now if you have to it was a
raccoon eating hamburger like a person
you need to stop banging your pen on
your desk or it's going to drive me
insane does anyone have a first aid kit
check out this song I I'm a love you
downstairs
tonight A hurg all right here we go
everybody get ready in three two good
luck
one
that